in the very first chapter of One Piece
shank sacrifices his arm and gives the
seven-year-old Luffy his Straw Hat this
is to inspire Luffy to become king of
the Pirates and at the same time Luffy
begs Shanks to let him join the red hair
Pirates however Shanks refuses so that
Luffy can create his own crew 10 years
later when he's 17 which kicks off the
story that we know today but this makes
us wonder what would have happened if
Shanks had actually let Luffy join his
crew What If instead of creating the
straw hats Luffy had become a red hair
pirate our story of course starts right
at the beginning of one piece when Luffy
meets Shanks for the very first time
Lothian Shanks are the exact same people
as in the main storyline the only thing
that needs to change here is that Luffy
actually gets to join the crew before
the redhead Pirates leave his village so
we gotta ask ourselves why doesn't
Shanks allow Luffy to join in the first
place well he actually gives us not one
but three reasons one because Luffy
can't swim because he is too young and
because the pirate life would be too
dangerous for him and I hope you agreed
that none of these are probably the real
reason I mean Shanks himself was found
by the first pirate king Goldie Roger as
a baby so Shanks was part of one of the
most dangerous pirate Crews when he was
Luffy's age and it doesn't look like he
regretted even a single moment of it and
yes it's true that Luffy can't swim but
the same goes for literally any other
devil fruit user ever and we even see
that the rest of shanks's crew is
actually very much in favor of Luffy
joining as well so what is shanks's real
reason to leave Luffy behind well one
possibility is that Shanks literally
can't take Luffy because he cannot swim
one really interesting fact about
shanks's crew is that not a single one
of his members have eaten a devil fruit
so maybe Shanks knows a place that you
can only swim to and therefore he
doesn't allow any non-swimmers to join
his crew or maybe it's because Shanks
wanted Luffy to grow and prove himself
without the help of a yonko after all if
you've watched any of my past what if
videos you will know that I strongly
believe that Shanks was planning for
Luffy to become pirate king right from
the start of the story so maybe ichiroda
the author of One Piece simply did it
because otherwise he wouldn't have been
able to write the story the way he
wanted to now I'm sure that we'll get an
answer for this in the future but for
now let's assume that after Luffy eats
his devil fruit Shanks actually changes
his mind if Luffy's the one who will
become pirate king and change the world
he figures the safest way to get there
is by training and protecting Luffy
himself and Luffy is of course extremely
hyped about this he is now officially
The Cabin Boy of the red hair Pirates
and from here on out the flow of the
story starts to change quite
dramatically the incidents with the
mountain bandits in the bars still
happens Luffy is still enraged about
Shanks not fighting back but band
backman tells him that you will
understand one day why Jinx did it puts
Luffy on his shoulders and the redhead
Pirates leave Luffy's Island the very
same day and this means that Luffy is
never kidnapped by the mountain Bandits
and as a result Shanks never loses his
arm now as you probably know Shanks
actually sacrificed his stronger arm
that he used to hold his sword with in
the main storyline before he let the Sea
King bite it off to inspire Luffy Shanks
was actually able to fight on the same
level as dracul mihawk the world's
strongest swordsman so if Luffy would
actually join shanks's crew Shanks
actually keeps his legendary sword
fighting abilities which is a huge game
changer now this may already seem like a
pretty big change but it is nothing
compared to this next one and so in this
version of the story Luffy only knows
about Ace from his grandfather's stories
and he only learns about Sabo years
later when running into the
Revolutionary Army as a result the three
of them never become brothers which as
you will see will make marineford
completely different but Ace still joins
the Whitebeard Pirates of course now
since Shanks didn't save Luffy's life
from the Sea King Luffy doesn't get
inspired to be become Pirate's King his
new dream instead is to become the
strongest pirate in shanks's crew and
make his captain pirate King instead
however just how Whitebeard was secretly
planning for Ace to find the one piece
and take over the Whitebeard pirates in
the end Shanks is also planning to make
Luffy pirate king one day after all
Luffy has still eaten his unique devil
fruit and he still resembles shanks's
former Captain Roger so while the red
hat Pirates are sailing away from
Luffy's home Island and having a welcome
party for their newest member Shanks
suddenly becomes very serious
purposefully sailed the ship into the
Khan belt where the Giants sea Kings
attack any ship that tries to cross
through it now Luffy himself is shocked
at the giant creature suddenly towering
above the ship but Shanks has been
waiting for just this moment right Gojo
appear in the sky as the man with the
strongest conquerors hockey in the world
knocks out all of the giant sea monsters
with one single burst of hockey the
planks of the ship itself Creak under
the pressure but Chang's who just like
Rayleigh in the auction house and Saba
ODI has perfect control over his powers
has excluded the seven-year-old Luffy
from its effect and of course Luffy at
that moment as you can imagine looks at
Shanks like he is some sort of God and
this is exactly what Shanks has been
hoping for just like in the main
storyline after sacrificing his arm he
makes Luffy promise to become a strong
pirate and one day surpass him and even
in this storyline I still think that he
would give Luffy the straw hat that he
had gotten from Roger as a kid as well
so instead of training with Ace and Sabo
in the jungles of the island Luffy now
grows up on shanks's ship as you can
imagine he very quickly grows Incredibly
Close to all of the main crew members
who now raise him instead of the bandits
and of course there are still a lot of
similarities to our main timeline Luffy
he has a very similar dream that drives
him to become stronger he still has his
Straw Hat he still lives a life of
Freedom training eating and sleeping
under the stars and he still has a
strong sense of justice and wants to
help people however the red hair Pirates
aren't Mountain Bandits and so a few
years after joining the crew Shanks
becomes known as one of the four
Emperors of the sea in other words he
now has one of the four strongest pirate
crews in the world who are now all
training Luffy and so as you would
expect this changes how Luffy develops
drastically compared to growing up with
Ace and Sabo don't worry Luffy is still
able to run and goof around quite a lot
for example I could totally see him
having a great time with monster this
monkey that is actually an officer on
shanks's crew Shanks himself would of
course teach Luffy all about haki very
early on in his life soon realizing that
Luffy also has the potential to Congress
haki which of course surprises no one in
the crew Shanks also teaches Luffy how
to fight with a sword although just like
in the actual story I don't think Luffy
would be great with swords instead as
you can probably tell from my thumbnail
I think it would be really cool if Luffy
got inspired by Ben Beckman and usop's
father yasop to start using a gun as we
know Luffy himself isn't stupid he just
doesn't know much about the world
because he was raised by Mountain
Bandits and running around with his
brothers all day in the jungle on board
of shanks's ship however I think Luffy
would still be his normal freeding
loving self always hungry but get a
really good education about all types of
things on top this includes geography
the different races that exist the
balance of the powers between Marines
the Warlords and the Emperors and so on
and so forth Oda has revealed after all
that Ben Beckman is the smartest person
from the East blue in the world so it
would be really interesting to see Luffy
take on a slightly more serious and
calculating side with his influence and
of course maybe most importantly his
outfit would look significantly more
badass than it does for most of the main
storyline oh and uh speaking of yasop
not only do I see him teaching Luffy how
to use a gun and observation hockey but
there is another thing that I could
totally see happening other two what-if
videos I've made so far about what if
Luffy was never born or what if Luffy
became a marine a common theme is that
Usopp always dies after all without
Luffy and zaro coming to fight the Kudo
Pirates usop's Village is simply overrun
and the entire island is taken out and
so since people have been complaining in
the comments a lot about killing of usab
every time I think we finally found a
scenario to keep him alive because if
Shanks allows Luffy to join even though
he's too young why shouldn't yasob get
his son as well not only do we know that
he felt extremely guilty for leaving USA
behind in the first place but both usop
and Luffy would have someone their own
age in the crew and I'm sure that Shanks
would approve of this as well
considering he grew up with buggy on
Roger's ship too and so in this version
of the story The Redhead Pirates
actually dropped by syrup Village to
pick up usob who also goes on to become
a brave Warrior of the sea and one of
the most powerful fighters in the world
this time growing up without any daddy
issues now since there's no one with a
devil fruit and shanks's crew you might
think that Luffy's devil food Powers
might get neglected here but when you
really think about it Luffy also had no
one else with a devil fruit growing up
either around him and he still managed
to develop his skills just fine in fact
I would argue that Shanks and Co not
only have fought with enough powerful
devil producers to teach Luffy the
basics and help him develop different
techniques but on top of that they also
know the actual truth about his unique
devil fruits and so to unlock his true
potential they might tell him about the
true power of His abilities or at least
guides him to the right decisions so I
would expect Luffy to awaken his devil
fruit Powers at a quite young age isn't
that right Gojo after all after becoming
a yonko Shanks would spend most of his
time in the new world where he started
to establish his own territory and so
Luffy would undoubtedly run into tons of
skirmishes and other larger battles with
other powerful pirate groups and Marines
all the time giving him more and more
chances to practice his abilities this
of course also includes encounters with
the likes of big mom kaido and
whitebeards which would be cool because
especially during the latter he would
befriend Ace as a rival since they are
both from the same island and have the
same grandfather and then once he would
actually awaken his devil fruit Shanks
for the first time would tell Luffy
about laughtail and being part of
Roger's crew igniting the spark in Luffy
to go see the final Island for himself
which now brings us to the point where
Luffy actually starts his Adventure in
the main storyline what is going to
happen to all of the others raw hats Oh
but before we get into that it's a new
year but luckily some of the best things
in life do stay the same like my
partnership with my favorite snack box
company boxu now boxer has not only been
supporting this channel for almost an
entire year now but they've also kept
sending me these delicious snack boxes
every month to make sure that I fail
with my fitness goals within pretty much
the first month of 2023. actually
originally they sent me their shinshu
New Year box which I accidentally ate
completely before recording so they
actually surprised me with their special
Sakura in Kyoto box instead that's right
cherry blossom season is around the
corner and voxo has worked with family
businesses all over Japan to deliver a
box packed with limited edition Sakura
themed snacks I mean look at all this
fantastic stuff I would probably sell my
cat for more of these matcha cookies
actually let me try some of these Sakura
cookies first
all right they're both absolutely
delicious and in case you don't know the
drill yet you can use my code ohara15
for 15 bucks off your very first own
boxu Japanese snack box because at this
point Luffy has already become a real
monster that is well known throughout
the world who has established himself as
one of shanks's core crew members as you
can imagine without Luffy there to save
them many of the straw hats would be
doomed and the East blue Saga would
become pretty damn dark if you really
wanted to you could of course say that
Luffy is strong enough at this point to
just start his own pirate crew and still
meets his original people but way
stronger This Time by the way if you're
interested in the video about what that
would look like with a super powerful
gear 5 Luffy make sure to subscribe and
let me know in the comments but I don't
think that it would be the most natural
thing for Luffy to do at this point
right now but at least we have saved USA
so that's something right but when Luffy
joins shanks's Crew He never gets to
save Kobe from alvida ship he also
doesn't make it to the Marine base where
Zorro is being starved to death and as a
result the strongest swordsman in the
world doesn't survive meanwhile at the
baratia Sanji stays there as a cook but
I believe that the vinsmoke family would
still find out about him sooner or later
and would still try to marry him off for
their alliance with big mom and as a
result Sanji would get assassinated at
the wedding party with pudding meanwhile
arlong steals Hall of Nami savings and
then forces her to keep working as a
cartographer for many more years now
moving on to the Grand line here it is a
lot more likely that Luffy might
actually encounter at least some of the
straw hats after all the yonko and their
crews are all moving around the grand
line all the time and we also know that
Shanks has been growing his crew quite a
bit since he first met Luffy 10 years
ago so really it would not be that hard
for Luffy to convince him to let someone
else join now first of all Luffy would
definitely get to meet crocus who just
like Shanks is a former member of the
Raja pirates in the actual official
timeline Shanks actually told both
Rayleigh and crocus about Luffy who were
waiting for him at the entrance of the
first and second half of the grand line
respectively crocus telling Luffy about
love tale and giving the crew the log
pose while Rayleigh helped Luffy train
and get stronger for two full years so
in this version of the story Shanks also
introduces Luffy to crocus directly and
Luffy gets to meet la boom and promise
him to come back Chopper could really go
either way I mean it's definitely
possible that Shanks and Co make a stop
at drum Island at some point and Luffy
just picks him up but at the same time
he might also just never go there and
Chopper simply ends up living with Dr
kureha under Waffle's terrible rule
Robin would either stay with crocodile
who would most likely succeed in taking
over Alabaster or Luffy might run into
her at some point and make her join as
well we actually don't know if Shanks
has anyone his crew right now that is
capable of reading the pony glyphs but
in case there is not Robin would be an
incredibly valuable asset NL is of
course still going to the Moon pretty
much nothing changes here Frankie stays
on water 7 but would probably be
discovered by Luchi and zp9 at some
point during their undercover mission to
get the plans of pluton and as usual
Brooke sooner later gets a shadow back
when Moria is inevitably defeated at
some point and Brooke becomes a global
Superstar now Luffy does of course meet
Rayleigh on sabaori archipelago though
just like with crocus Shanks introduces
the person that Roger has been waiting
for to his former Vice Captain now
crocus decided to stay behind because he
wanted to take care of laboon but with
Rayleigh I could absolutely see him
joining the red chair Pirates to help
with Luffy's training and to make sure
that he ends up finding the one piece in
order to change the world which now
brings us to the word marine for it
which does get really really interesting
in this specific scenario now even
though Luffy and A's never became
Brothers a still goes after Blackbeard
he still gets captured and the war
between Whitebeard and the Marines is
still bound to happen only that this
time while Luffy is definitely angry he
doesn't have the exact same motivation
to actually go and save Ace instead he
accompanies Shanks to wano who is trying
to stop kaido to get involved in the war
as well as he does in the main storyline
now this of course means that the prison
break in impell down never happens which
would mean that Jim day stays in prison
while Blackbeard and his crew are all
defeated by Magellan when they try to
invade the prison but let's actually
assume for a second that Blackbeard and
his crewmates actually managed to go
down all the way to level 6. because in
that case Blackbeard would once again
tell all the level 6 prisoners that the
last person surviving in their cell
could join his crew which would mean
that jimbei would most likely end up
joining Blackbeard's crew even if it
would be kind of against his will now
one big question is of course how did
Shanks manage to stop kaido from joining
the war in the first place who knows
maybe the two Crews actually fought but
when Shanks and his men arrive at
marineford in the main storyline they
don't look like they've just fought a
gigantic Dragon so instead I think it's
much more likely that Shanks actually
just went and talked to kaido and so
while the two Yonka would have a meeting
on onigashima Luffy would surely run
around and finally run into no one other
than Yamato Luffy then tells Yamato
about Ace being captured and about his
upcoming execution and since Yamato is
of course friends with A's she wants to
come and save him as a result Luffy
secretly frees Yamato from her shackles
and smuggles her on board of Shanks of
then they finally make it to Marine
for it but just like in the main
storyline it is already too late Ace has
been killed and Blackbeard has gone in
and stolen whitebeard's devil fruit now
Shanks and his men are once again able
to stop the War this time Luffy is
actually part of the Epic intro of the
red hat Pirates he transforms into his
awakened form and stands between aokiji
and Marco the gorosei and many people
who are watching the live broadcast of
the war are shocked at Luffy's true
appearance sengoku after a quick moment
of shock announces to the world once
again that Luffy is the son of monkey
the dragon the World's Most Wanted Man
and an officer of the red hair Pirates
now Luffy himself meanwhile is
completely unfazed by all this instead
he has to stop Yamato from attacking
Akainu who is mocking AIDS and while
Shanks is negotiating with sengoku about
taking Aces and whitebeard's bodies to
bury them Luffy rushes to his
grandfather who is heartbroken about
Aces death now after the war things
could go in many different directions I
could either see Luffy actually leaving
shanks's crew to find his own path and
crew or Luffy stays with Shanks and soon
overtakes Ben Beckman as the second
strongest man in the crew and right-hand
man in that case Shanks would most
likely start preparation to reach Loft
tail soon and make Luffy pirate king or
a third alternative would be that Luffy
passes on his Straw Hat to someone else
like momonoski for example encouraging
the Next Generation to find the one
piece and change the world but if you
want to go down a really crazy route
think about this what if Luffy didn't
fight as part of shanks's crew at Marine
Ford what if he had fought next to a
kainu kizaru and aokiji in other words
what would have happened if instead of a
pirate Luffy had become a Marine to find
out you can simply click right here and
watch that video thanks for watching